I got burnt out so much and also because
I was like in this weird obsessive thing
I refused to take holiday days I think
it was something ridiculous where I'd
finished here on like 20 days left or
something obscene like that which
looking back is like so dumb welcome
back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Tisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Megan from few
and far so you started your recruitment
career in 2016. yeah and you've
ultimately just progressed the ranks all
the way to A.D associate director
she's always been within the tech space
always been a permanent recruiter her
best year today has been 330 Grand with
her best performing month being 82 Grand
but she still hasn't quite been able to
top last year you guys as a team did 700
which was a big number for you guys in
that sub team you personally did 227
last year Megan is really committed to
her craft and her crew which she talks a
lot about and the sacrifices that have
had to come with that during her early
career we also talk about her journey of
leadership where she always got told
that she'd be a great manager but like
the idea of just focusing on her own
buildings and performance but over the
last couple of years that's really
changed and she's been on a really great
journey in getting the most out of her
team while still fulfilling her own
potential what are your thoughts on the
characteristics and traits that you
believe make up a highly successful
recruit in today's market I would say
the number one thing that I look for and
that looking back I think is so
important is
[Music]
so let's get into this week's
F Megan welcome to the podcast thank you
thank you thanks for having me thanks
for making the trip obviously recently
moved yes I'm an apparently a nestic
skill now but yeah
I don't I don't think that will come
into fruition I don't feel like it where
did you grow up
um a place called scunthorpe in North
Lincolnshire I'm always trying to work
out your accent I wasn't sure where that
was from I think after like nine nine
nearly 10 years in London it's like I
don't know people can never guess where
I'm from yeah some people pick up on it
yeah
um so really excited to sit down with
you today uh there's a lot that I know
that we want to cover as always I'd just
like to give everyone listening to some
immediate context of
of your journey so
you've you know you're coming up to a
decade in recruitment
am I yeah three years three years
18 months pretty much okay crazy yeah I
think you're on you're on on the past a
decade in in recruitment right so that's
mad in terms of some of the the
highlights on on this journey so far so
you started your recruitment career in
2016. yeah
um in the dot debt Market but
specifically just the fs Market in
London souvenirs right so work for that
initial company for three years you as
always an individual contributor at that
company your best year I think this
still today I might be wrong but yeah
especially today
um free 30 biggest month 82 still
haven't been able to crack that no so
annoying
um so first three years
was there then joined another company
and then for the last three years which
is the journal that we're gonna really
uh focus on you've been at few and far
um and you've ultimately just progressed
the ranks all the way to A.D associate
director
um so now uh currently if I'm wrong but
you're a team of uh free four yeah of
course yeah three people with me right
now
um I know
um in terms of something you was really
proud of last year you guys um as a team
did 700 which was
um a big number for you guys in that sub
team you personally did 227 last year
um and we're here to talk about this
journey that you've been on yeah so
let's start with the million pound
question and if you've gone on this
journey to you know hire people for your
team
what are your thoughts on the
characteristics and traits that you
believe make up a highly successful
recruit in today's market
I I would say the number one thing that
I look for and that looking back I think
is so important is
mindset like a positive mindset and
attitude because it stems into
everything that you do like every
conversation you have like let's face it
there's some awful days in recruitment
where like you finished saying just like
why do I do this so I think like having
that that ability to come in the next
day and think right you know you've
Shrugged it off let's go again
um I think that's super important
because it is so up and down like it's
important to like like know yourself
enough to be like resilient I know how
you're gonna like bounce back come back
in the next day let's do it again
um along with that I think is like that
that drive and like desire to be good at
something and and hard work
um yeah especially in like the first
three is like
I was a bit of a monster like just
obsessed um working like ridiculous
hours like literally wake up go to work
go home sleep repeat four years
um that's not the right thing to do like
there's definitely a balance there but I
think you need to you need to be driven
and kind of in inside know your why as
well right like you know recruitment is
about ultimately you can make good money
but you need to know like why you're
doing this because it's not it's not
easy
um yeah along alongside that I think
um just being like authentic and like
likable of course like it's all about
relationships right like you're speaking
to people day in day out
um so I think that's a really key thing
as well
um and yeah I think I think it just
helps to
to like find find something that you
enjoy within it that you can
um every day
like not think it's like God would want
terrible job like
um and kind of like yeah just just like
really want to better yourself I think
those things are really important I
think you can teach this you can teach
the skill right everyone always says
this like I've hired someone who had
like a couple months experience but they
had the right attitude and teach them
the skills and now they're like smashing
it so something good so much of it is is
a mindset isn't it yeah
you just you can hear me fine now can't
you um
so what I wanted to start with because
like when we what was very apparent when
we prepared for this was like the work
ethic piece yeah because I think that's
something that you feel quite proud of
um I don't know and then I like I said
to you I um I messaged uh Sam one of
them
and like that was one of the first
things that you said like Megan's
probably you know one of the the hardest
working people in the room and I know if
I'll give her a task or whatever I know
she'll [__] get it done
where like where where's this stem from
like have you have you felt like maybe
it's like convolved over time because
like you said to me those first three
years in recruitment like you just
absolutely just committed everything
which obviously meant other things
sacrificed right whether that be your
well-being the social side of things
whatever I don't know but like where you
know why why is that important to you if
you've always felt like since coming to
London you've got a point to prove
you've got a chip in your shoulder I
don't know you you tell us like why why
is that because that's something that
you I picked up on quite quickly like I
work my absolute [__] socks off and I
will make sure it happen
yeah I remember even in my like before I
was in recruitment in like when I was
graduating in my first interview
I remember they asked like where does
this like Drive come from because I was
at Uni and I was like I hadn't got my I
hadn't got my final degree but I was
like I'm gonna get a first and they're
like how do you know and I was like
because I just um
um
it's it's a weird thing like I've
obviously reflects on it a lot over
recruitment I don't I think it does stem
a little bit from
moving to London
um being from like you know a really
small town area I think there is that
slight element of like point to prove um
my brother was really successful like
when I got into recruitment he owned a
recruitment company we've always had a
bit of like healthy competition
um he's an accountant now so it's all
right
um so yeah it's it's a strange thing but
it just comes from I think within like
just wanting to make make a name for
myself
um and every day like be better like be
good at what I do because
it's bordering on like toxic toxic like
competitiveness but it's like if you
don't want to be the best at something
what's the point like there is a there's
a balance to that but
um yeah it's just
a weird thing within me like I can't I
can't just I don't want to be average
yeah and I try and instill that into my
team as well
I'm just curious because I don't know uh
I don't know how many people you've
interviewed or met for like your team
and stuff but just speaking to a lot of
uh leaders managers recruitment owners
past six 12 months
um definitely generalization and I've
said it before but definitely from the
conversations I've had people feel like
they don't have a lot of people they
meet that don't have what you're
describing
um but still expect
you know the six figures and everything
that comes with being great in
recruitment but you know are gonna come
in at nine finish at 5 30. I don't know
like it's I don't know if you're if you
found yourself you come across that
lesson lesson people
when it comes to interviewing I remember
we were running running like a we call
it a talent scout Academy just sort of
people that have no experience in
recruitment will interview and like I
probably interview maybe like 30 people
and I only said yes to like two or three
I remember the internal recruit was like
you you are just ridiculous like you're
so hard to please but yeah I think it's
I think it is important like you it's
hard to fish that out right you can't
just like interview someone like are you
gonna you know sacrifice things like to
to get where you want to be
um yeah I think I think it is quite hard
to find but if someone is like if
someone comes in they're like I I want
this like I want to be good at something
then you know they're like get to know a
little bit about their why
um you know what why would you want to
do that
um then I think I think that helps
um do you think do you think you would
have
because I I'm I'm I have my own thoughts
on this in terms of I think the way when
you when you were saying they're around
like it's sort of you know borderline
toxic and there's balance there for me I
I think like I'm in no position to say
what's too much for Megan in terms of
like you know the what how much work
you're putting in these things I do
think it's it is very individual but I
think it's it's up to the individual if
they want to you know put a lot of uh
energy and time into uh work or for me I
really like to view things as Seasons as
chapters like right now I'm in the
season of like I really need to put a
lot of time into work however when I'm
not in work I have to be really good at
being present and like you know not not
being there
um but I think you know it's it's almost
gone the other way now where I work work
ethic and working really hard and doing
these things is also almost seen as like
a bad thing and like you shouldn't be
doing that so do you do you think you
would have done those sorts of numbers
in those first three years without that
sacrifice
probably not
um to be honest
um I think I would have again probably
would have been like you know average to
good but I wanted to be great and I I
knew that if I put in those you know the
extra hour two hours after the work
hours finished like that was gonna get
gain me that extra step
um so yeah I probably wouldn't have I
think it I think a lot of it did stem
down to being almost obsessed
um so what did those days look like then
like in terms of like how long did that
when did they start when did they finish
what when you was like all in unlike
recruitment just like I am going to be
the best I'm gonna outwork all of you
like I've got a point to prove like what
did like a normal day look like so I
remember I used to get in the office for
about half seven sometimes earlier
um would would be like on the phones for
eight so before then
um I remember I was I was sharing a
market with other people as well like
other people in the market so back back
then like we mainly like we did a lot of
like job board I think um like you know
to sweep candidates like we didn't have
a recruiter license so I would be like
I'm gonna be the first one in because
I'm gonna be the first one that goes on
the job board see see who's come in
overnight and I'm gonna be the first one
to contact them like so
um then like yeah that was very like kpi
heavy like the days would fly because
you're just on the phone all the time
um and then
yeah that it was a lot of like phone
phone based and then they would finish
probably eight sometimes nine I remember
the MD once was like get out of the
office and I was like no like I need to
finish this one thing so yeah some
sometimes it was it was that heavy like
literally half seven until like eight
half eight yeah some sometimes later
that was fairly normal
yeah so what what was the sacrifice then
like what what happened on like
what yeah what was the sacrifice Journal
periods for you I think the sacrifice
was
like having no down time in the week
like as as well as that like you know as
me metloads of good people there because
we're all sort of like share similar
values and doing a similar thing so
I think that led to a lot of burnout
ultimately like a sacrifice like
my own sort of like well-being and
mental health a lot
um I got burnt out so much and also
because I was like in this weird
obsessive thing like I refused to take
holiday days like I think I think it was
something ridiculous where I'd finished
here on like 20 days left or something
or scene like that which looking back is
like so dumb like why why was I doing
that but yeah it was just it was just
this thing of like was you aware you was
doing it while she was in there like
kind of but I think that was like my
be-all and end all like my purpose to it
because also like living in London let's
face it as expensive right you're on a
you're in it for for the commission like
I was um you know gotta pay the rent pay
the bill so I was also really driven to
that like I remember
back then I was living in like Hendon
like Northwest London it was always my
goal that I really wanted to move to
Canary Wharf and I was like yeah that
was like always my goal three years
later I did
um so I lived there for like six years
and
um but yeah I think the sacrifice was
just like living a life
you know in the phrase like I was
um living to work not working to live
um and now I try I try find that balance
for sure like last year went on like
three holidays this year I've been on
two like so yeah that that's definitely
not Shrugged off me now but yeah please
don't overwork yourself you've got to
live some of somewhat of a life but like
but then
just and then just to wrap this up
though like would you change it though
yeah that's the thing like I think I
think I would make small changes like I
wouldn't have been so like all in like I
would have given like you know I would
have took took a week off like gone
it's like definitely wouldn't you're
like you know what no I think you
obviously would have learned a lot you
committed to it so much would have come
from that but if you took that week off
I'm sure you still would have yeah got
to where you got to yeah yeah I think I
think looking back I would I would have
took more breaks because that also makes
you better as well right like when when
you're more when you're well rested and
also have that time for self-reflection
you can come back in even even better
like I had a holiday the end of June
came back and was like feeling amazing
like so so up for it like I didn't real
you don't realize like but you need
those breaks
[Music]
um to kind of like yeah just reflect on
what's gone well what what hasn't
changes you want to make
um so yeah
in the early days it's it's tough
so
uh something that I found an interesting
when we're preparing for this
um was how you said that a lot of the
time you were told that
you'd be you'd make a good manager but
you really wanted to just focus on doing
deals and worrying about yourself
what was that
um I think it was just this thing where
like
I think it was a realization I'm
devoting all this time to myself like I
don't have more time to give to someone
else
um I think I was just really like driven
to be
like I'm doing this for me like I don't
I don't I don't want a team I don't want
to manage and I said that for ages like
at all my companies it's like you'd be a
good manager I was like no
um so yeah I think it's only since
coming to few and far that I actually
realized I actually I probably would and
I'm somewhere that I really enjoying
like fully aligned to the values of the
company and I'm not working like a dog
like I I can dedicate some time and like
it I've now realized actually that that
like gives me so much
um like impacting other people seeing
them progress
so yeah it's just the I think
comfortability and just like a
realization and also a thing of like I
don't want to be like a I see for life
you know like I wanted to I didn't know
what was next from there but yeah it's
definitely the best decision for me for
sure
yes I'm I'm really Keen to go into the
management leadership piece I guess what
would be really interesting for people
then like I I asked you didn't I like
if younger Megan was listening to this
conversation like what is it that
you know you'd love us talk about or
things that you'd be really interested
in we've spoken a lot about you know
working a lot on putting in uh the hours
and just being really committed
so I think you know one of the things
that you said was like you know if I if
Megan was listening to this like three
years ago what you'd be really
interested in is like how you can get
more out of your your time right because
there's a lot to be said like you know
work work smarter not harder that whole
phrase
so there'll be a lot of people listening
to this that might be on that hamster
wheel or might be on that right I'm just
absolutely you know I'm in the phase
where I need to just put the hours in
but you know we've we've we've got the
the luxury of of hindsight now so like
you know looking back at that period was
looking back at the the years that
you've worked really hard you put the
hours in
you know what have been some of the
things which I'm sure over time you've
you've had to just um improve on and get
better at so you're not just working for
work sake because let's be honest if
you're working half seven eight till uh
whatever time there's gonna be periods
in that time where you're not being
productive
so like you know what what have you
learned through that period
um you know or throughout this journey
to be like right this is how I set
myself up to make sure that
I actually feel productive at the end of
the day and I'm you know getting close
to the outcomes I want
that is like managing your time like
sometimes I feel like I say sometimes
I'm like there's just sometimes there's
just not enough hours in the day to do
what I want to do but I have to be
realistic
um I set myself goals whether that's
like
yearly break it down into quarterly
monthly weekly daily so so now I come in
and I'm not trying to do like a hundred
things I'm I'm doing 10 things but I'm
doing them really well and that's still
going to get like it's things that are
going to take you a step further to
to the year goal you know like you just
I've learned a lot more to break that
down and learn that well enough where I
can help my team do that as well so what
does that look like then because I'm
assuming you didn't do that when you was
in the early years not really I think I
think that was just like speak to as
many people as you could physically
could yeah yeah
oh whereas now I think it's just being
more like
selective with with what you do
um who you speak to
um so if it's a breakdown a year then
what do you just break down your yearly
Target
yeah pretty much like it it definitely
helps to
focus on what you know promotions you
want to achieve other things that you
want to do in the job but also outside
of the job as well like like we said
that why you know like I want to build x
amount okay look how much commission
will that bring in what do you want to
do with that
um and then working backwards from there
and keep like revisiting those goals
um so yeah it just just helps to like
have have goals then then you know if
you've had a good week or not or a good
a good month or not say if you haven't I
don't know say if you haven't build in a
month like
again comes back to positive attitude
like how do you still look back and be
like you know what I still I still did
that and that that's got me a step
closer to
to doing doing you know some a great
month the month after so that you're not
like just falling into a negative hole
of like goddamn I'm bad at this
um so
yeah I just think I was tough like
realistic weekly weekly plans and divide
that into your days
um
yes
um because I think that'll be helpful
for people so
um
I guess on a monthly basis like you're
looking at like I want you you know the
team say like I wanna
I wanna build x amount because I want to
do x with the money like I'm planning
this later in the year or whatever I
want to pay off this credit card
whatever so
um but it's like okay well how how are
you gonna do that what what jobs you are
you working like I think I Rely a lot on
like ratios as well I think that's
always really good to look at
um so like okay I want to do three Deals
all right well how many CVS do you send
to do a deal so let's break that down
into week by week so how many CVS you
can send a week
um just just relying on the data
um knowing what works for each person I
think no one's weekly plan is the same
as well because you all have different
ratios you're all doing slightly
different things at different like skill
levels
um and things like yeah how many you
know how many people do you want to meet
like I try like how many events do you
want to go to this month or quarter
um even down to things like how many
times you want to post on LinkedIn this
week um it's like spinning all those
plates doing different things like
um yeah you know how many companies you
want to aim to reach out to um so yeah
those are like the well the key ratios
that you always keep an eye on
um I think CV to placement is always
like a a one that um I like to be like
proud of that we've done
um
like I think mine this year's like six
or seven to a placement which I'm like
super happy with
um and yeah I think CV to first as well
because if it's like
too high then you know that you didn't
qualify the job right or you really
don't understand what you're looking for
at all
um so yeah those are the key things that
I tend to look at to be fair yeah I
think it's so it is so helpful to break
it all down I wish I did way more of
that when even even like now you know
trying to grow a business like there's
so many different plates and it you know
like I've tried to incorporate these
things and anchoring them back to the
quarterly goal or the yearly go and then
you know working back from there
it does help a lot because I think we
can all fall into the Trap of like
setting a goal and then sort of
not looking at it again or not speaking
about it again until we get closer to it
um so that's super interesting then I
guess
obviously how how have you found this
year
oh it's been it's been for it's been
pretty tough
I think every recruiter will say that
it's definitely getting better now like
I'm feeling way more positive the past
like couple months but earlier this year
was
really tough like yeah the the team the
business haven't had the best the best
start to the year but
um yeah you know as we know in the tech
Market
just a few of my clients didn't get
their next funding around some of them
just went went bus you know had to like
let go of people
um that I'd placed there
um a lot of layoffs as we know now a big
thing of like companies that are hiring
as well you know we'll just stick an
advert out we've got all these amazing
people and they're gonna apply to us but
so
um and I think it's like yeah there's a
lot of variables in it that's made it a
lot tougher to be honest just on the the
jobs that we've had I wanted to ask you
around the light because the most common
thing that you know the people that I've
continued to speak to have struggled
with is yeah consistently being able to
you know acquire good quality jobs
so like what what have you found
yourself really leaning into or what you
know what business development
strategies that really worked for you so
far this year because it has been tough
for most people that I've spoken to
it's got to be Network and relationships
like it just has to be that's number one
like
I do try I do do some like cold stuff
sometimes that pays off
um but for the most part
it's all about like who you know like
it's
it's that domino effect of you know
maybe what I did seven seven years ago
is now is now like coming to to help me
now
um but yeah I think it's about who you
know and like having given people
amazing experiences they're gonna come
back to you
um like as an example after like after
this today I've got an intro call with a
company
um the candidate that I know that worked
there like introduced me to their team
because they're making a higher like I
never placed him but he was you know got
done happy with with the service that I
gave him everything I've helped him with
and having a good relationship with him
like I even just helps his girlfriend do
a CV like she who works in like sales so
it's just like having those like yeah
relationships I think that's like again
another conversation this month someone
that so before I'd placed them in the
past but they've gone somewhere new
they're struggling on a roll and he's
mentioned my name and they've reached
out to me to chat so I think that's
really important that you know that that
all stems from the work that you do
every day and is like making sure you
give it your best that you
it just yourself you like give people an
amazing experience you go above and
beyond like wherever you can I think
that that's always going to yield like
the best results
this podcast is proudly partnered with
vincere the all-in-one recruitment
agency software that over 20 000
recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning one-up
sales and motivation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your teams we love partnering with both
of these organizations because they
share our mission in helping you get the
most out of your people and your
business you can get exclusive offers
because you listen to this podcast and
get up to 10 of the usage price forever
use a link in the show notes to get your
hands on that let's get back to the
episode curious I will speed someone
about this yesterday actually so it's
top of mind
I'm in complete agreement with you I
think most people would but I think what
a lot of people are curious about is
like how
you go about building those
relationships I know you said really
Double Down On The Experience yeah um
and delivering great experience but
someone I wanted to ask you I know
you've uh I don't know how like how it
works exactly in your industry but I'm
assuming there's still very much a lot
of remote working or not
I think there's been a big shift to be
honestly the reason why I asked is um I
speak to someone yesterday and they were
just really curious a lot about how
because they're an agreement they
approach things how you approach things
but they were very much like how do
people
you know build good quality
relationships through a screen
yeah that's so true the the two examples
I gave just then like one of them lives
in Germany one of them lives in Spain
like I've never met them face to face so
I think
um it's about having like multiple touch
points like
obviously I do that and like once I've
reached out to someone say like I always
do it do as much as you can on video
call at least then you're just face to
face as you can be
um and just keeping in touch with them
like yeah really I was thinking about
this this morning as well as well
um just like
like yeah how different it is when you
can meet some like if if they're in
London great you can go go meet them but
it like when you've never when you've
never met someone in real life but
you're so close to them like it's just a
bit of a because it is a skill yeah like
being able to you know join a Google
meets or whatever and to sort of connect
with the person on the other side of the
screen
yeah I think just all stems down to
being like authentic and
um having like their best interests like
if asking how you know if you can help
them with enough with anything else then
go do it
um and then yeah just like speak
speaking to them really often like if if
they're in process with you obviously
like giving them even if there's no
update giving them an update like that
that's what's gonna yield them to think
that was such a good experience working
working with Megan
um and yeah I find like having be an
interest in their in their life and
things like that
um that that always helps because then
you've got all you know other things
other things to chat about just try and
find out actually here there is yeah
exactly don't don't be a transactional
recruiter like I think I think we all
know that but yeah like have a gen have
a genuine interest in in them build that
like friendship almost
she said experience I'm just curious
like what
what are some of the things that you
think
you know you do really well that equates
to a candidate or even a client going
that was you know we didn't we didn't
end up going with Megan's candidate or
Megan didn't actually you know
um I didn't actually take the job that
Megan got offered to me I went to
another company but it was still a great
fantastic experience
like what what does that actually mean
what are some of those things that do
you think you're you've done and I'm
sure these have evolved over time like
what does it actually look like what are
some of the things that you're doing
throughout the evening candidate process
that equates to a great experience
it comes down to the
the like
uh communication piece
um being like like I said if you don't
have anything to even update them on
just let them know that you know I've
not had any feedback yet like how's
things going
um
being really like involved in their
process as well like so let's say
you prepare someone really well like
that could be on the phone and you send
an email like I've I've made like over
my career like a a general first
interview preparation like Playbook me
and my team use that so I make sure that
like it's I feel it's like a foolproof
way to not to pass a first interview
um making like bespoke prep for for each
company that you work with
and candidates really appreciate that
right because then they're not going in
blind like sometimes I do say like it's
probably Overkill but I'd rather you
over prep than under and they always
really appreciate that doing you know
when they're like a little good luck
text before
um when they're finished you've got a
debrief booked in and then you just you
know having a chat with them about how
it went how they're feeling
um delivering that straight back to the
client so this like really like Smooth
process where everyone knows everyone
knows what's going on um
and yeah like I said that piece around
like having
everyone's kind of best interests at
heart which is sometimes hard to do hard
to please everyone but um you know if
like yeah if like knowing what other
people have going on trying to like
really relate relay it back to that
initial conversation we've had with
someone where you understand their
motivations like you understand where
they want to be in three five years time
and kind of like
um like career coaching them almost like
even if that's not for your role if you
feel like it they're not going to take
it but I'll still help coach them
towards the other two opportunities they
have
um as well as that like if someone say
like falls out of process with me like
let's say that they're unsuccessful in
the interview where I can like if I see
like a like a company hiring for a role
that I think they'd be interested in
um then I'll send it to them
um no you're not working up yeah it
happened the other day I know this um
it's like a head avenge CTO and he's
really into really into cars
um and I saw this like car car company
um hiring for a head of engineering
they've got they've got back to me in
the past and said like absolutely not
looking to work with agency so I just
sent it to him was like this looks
perfect for you he's like thank you so
much
um just doing little things like that
like if if someone's struggling in their
search
um
and that could even like a um like on
the client side like I was working with
someone in Talent they got me redundant
and I've been been helping them like
just completely free you know I'm not
looking to get looking to get free out
of it but companies were speaking to I'm
asking dude do you actually need a
remote anyone like remote and talent
like this is when I worked on this what
they've done do you want you want to
chat to them
um and also like again if I see things
on LinkedIn you know companies hiring
send it to them like this thought this
looks good for you so it's little things
like that where everybody yeah and I do
that autonomously I don't like I think
it's just ingrained in me now just like
just try and help people where you can
because that that's what that's what's
gonna
reap your rewards you know that's that's
the experience I'm a huge believer in
pen just paying it yeah yeah like what
because yeah it's just got a funny way
of coming back like you've experienced
like recently and I'm sure you've just
got like why it's probably become just
so you know unconscious for you to do it
is because you're one you know it's the
right thing to do
and two
um although you're not expecting
anything at some point there'll probably
be something that happens where you're
like oh like this this is lovely like
this person six months ago and then do
you know what I mean like I'm just a
huge believer in that Karma yeah yeah
it's official camera as a whole but
obviously appreciate sometimes that if
you that can be hard to like it's also
hard to see like where that can
um just how that's going to play out
especially as you're trying to build
your career right it's like you know you
can't go into your one-on-one managers
like yeah but I've like helped loads of
people yeah like yeah yeah
but I I appreciate you sharing all that
I guess just to get
granny left for a sec because I think
it'd be interesting for people as you
were
um talking about it just popped into my
head more on like the candidate so I
just have interest because clearly
you've had some intros recently and then
that's that's ended up in
um you know client opportunities like
what does what do the typical steps look
like in terms of your process so like if
they're going for uh the interviewing
for a job that you have I know every
company has different interview
processes let's say they have a two
stage interview process
like what what are what happens on each
step how do you approach it because I'm
sure this is where you thought about
experience because like you said okay
um first interview
um they're gonna you know we're gonna
have a call we're gonna go through my
Playbook or I don't know what the steps
are but would you mind just talking
through that because I think that would
be helpful for people or at least
interesting on like you know the typical
Journey that you take people on
at each stage or like leading up to
interviewing I think that'll be
interesting for people
it does all start with that initial we
call it like pre-screen but like that
that first call with them it's so so
important to find out as much as you can
about about them like what they've done
their their strengths but most
importantly like what they want to do
next like their underlying motivations
like what's important to them all of
their preferences and you know make sure
that you've got a role that actually
aligns to that like don't try and shoot
them into something that you you know is
not not gonna be right what do people
uses of your team sorry it's a button
but what do people often miss at that
stage because if you started there and I
love that you started the well it all
starts with new stuff you first speak to
Megan the candidate and actually do a
good job of understanding what's
important to them where do people
normally go wrong there
um
a few things really like I think
I think you can Overlook like what is
deeply deeply important to someone like
what's up like the types of progression
that they want to get I think you want
to you want someone to ideally stay
there for a while right but if if you're
like speaking to someone and they want
to be in a different career path in
three in three years time
um like you need to you need to know
what what is truly important for them
that's going to like gain them that
experience to get to where they want
they want to be I think that can be
skipped and then later down the line
they're like oh it doesn't really match
up with my my future like this is about
a long-term option for me
um
what else do people Miss
I think I think that's like the the main
thing I think it all stems from just
like aligning to what someone's
motivations are I think if you missed
that like it's never going to work well
I guess I guess people can get it but
when I speak to managers a lot of the
time it's like they can get at a surface
level yeah and they don't ask the second
question of like why is that important
to your wife is that why yeah it's
rather than me asking you going yeah I
really want to become a CTO in three
years okay great yeah and what channel
are you looking forward you know I mean
it's not like well why why do you want
to be a CTO yeah yeah it's like why what
what do you think is missing to get
there okay well in this opportunity you
could gain this this and this which is
going to help help you to get to that
next step and yeah just just those whys
like someone's like I really need remote
working okay cool but like knowing why
like this happened recently like why
well they're a single parent they've got
two kids that are in school like they
need they do all the school school runs
like okay cool that that's why it's you
know just just knowing that extra
information is going to really help you
to like match align them to something so
it all starts with the pre-screen yeah
what we're saying after that what
happened um
I think it's I think um one of the like
sounds weird one of the things I love
doing is like talking about an
opportunity like I really like I love
working with startups when I'm with
Founders when I know the business inside
out and it's like telling telling them
that story
um of that company like what they do
um the role where it could take you like
I love like sometimes I can spend like
15 minutes just talking and I'm like I'm
running out of time but I think just
like getting them engaged into that
opportunity and not just like
this is the role this is the tech suck
cool but like really like getting into
the grain like and getting their true
thoughts after that like okay what what
questions have you got like what what
you know any like concerns and just the
opportunity things have said from there
um
obviously it depends on them going
forward
um
the the preparation piece like I said
um making like bespoke preparation
because you know we're we're recruiters
like we know how to interview we help
people interview but some you know say
this person's not into it in a few years
like it might be a bit Rusty you want
them to be on their top form and help
help them so
um if someone's not feeling that
confident you could do like a little
like interview prep like almost like
role play like you know ask them if they
want that don't sort of push it on
someone but
um from there like I said before that
into you know people get people get
interview interview nerves like on that
day just wish them good luck and you
lost questions things like that have
that debrief booked in
yeah
um for me it's like always booked in
again on on a video call like hear them
out how how it all went the you know
just all the questions about
um if it's the right opportunity for
them don't be afraid to ask them if
there's any concerns like because you
wanted to make it happen but ask them
like is there any like you know red
flags yellow flags almost like what
questions have you still got in mind
like really just knowing what you need
to then
um you know ideally you'd advise the
client to like you know they really want
to find out more about this in the next
round
um
and then yeah like
throughout the process just though just
those multiple touch points
um
the next stage did you have another prep
yeah yeah yeah it's always different in
Tech of what like the second the
following stages look like but
um yeah like if if it's a a new client
just going with like what you think
might be relevant and again you say like
this is what I think is gonna this is
what similar clients who do a similar
interview process have said like not you
know it's not gospel but I hope it helps
sort of thing
um
and yeah just following that all the way
through like just making sure that they
they are happy that they're constantly
excited about it you know
um but I think that helps having a fast
process because you know if there's like
two week gaps then they kind of like
lose that momentum lose that enthusiasm
for it so it definitely helps when
you're when you've got a nice moving
process with like a
um
a good client
um but yeah that's it like um going into
the
like sort of final stages like you'd
expect you'd expect to know if they're
gonna take the opportunity or like
something would have to go like really
badly wrong in that final piece um
so
um yeah and then yeah where you can
celebrate with someone after if they are
local to you like you know ask how how
you're both gonna go celebrate or how
they're going to celebrate
and then what does Megan do in between
the stages where
you know vulnerable to stand at their
current company
well that's who you said
would love to get something and let's
celebrate
well is there anything else that you've
found yourself doing leading up to them
handing their notes starting where
things can
um yeah like
I've hope I've
um kept in search for people that have
been maybe had had some wobbles like to
be fair going back to earlier question
that is probably something that people
missing that initial thing is like if
they're leaving a company like truly
knowing why why yeah yeah because is it
is it about money that if you get
accounted I would probably take it if it
is just purely money so you definitely
need to know know that
um
yeah just just keep just keep in touch
with people like seeing how they're
feeling like having their their best
interests like sometimes it's hard but
you just sort of feel like put yourself
in their shoes like
um what sort of guidance would you need
and want right now
um
and yeah sometimes you do just have to
like you can't force people to take your
your offer your job like if it's not
right for them like you do have to
that's something I've learned like you
do have to think like actually yeah it's
that it's not gonna it's not gonna work
like but I wish you all the best like
you know and again those are the
situations where giving someone that
experience and saying like yeah
completely you know go for the other
offer you know you're not going to take
this then they're the ones like that
because I've given them that experience
because like I actually care and not
just like not just like pretending to
care
um that that will come full circle to
you at some point
um and they might be a future hiring
manager or like I said I recommend you
into where they join where they join
because they've been so happy with how
you've like treated them and the
experience you've given over maybe who
even got them that job so no yeah I know
we've been really grounded there but I
think that'd be helpful like especially
the fact that that's clearly that I'm
assuming that's also been
in terms of like a source of
uh client opportunity or hiring manager
want to speak to Mega and I'm assuming
you know one of those consistent sort of
sources for over your career has been
people that you delivered a good
experience with refer you in yeah I
think that can often be missed on it
like that's actually a brilliant way uh
that's just a yeah that could always be
going on if you just really commit to
doing a great experience yeah it's true
I had like a really full circle moment
the other week
um someone I'd worked with in 2017 when
I was just like so early in my career
and they were sort of like mid-level in
their career like they're now like a
head of engineering and you know now now
we're in in talks about helping him
build a team but I was just like that's
mad like from something you did six
years six years ago you know I've not
been in any small touch points with this
person but like
it will come around like hopefully you
won't have to wait six years but it will
it will come around like it is always
worth it yeah no yeah just and obviously
these things can often be forgotten
right just being really committed to
being creating a world-class experience
yeah even if they don't get the job yeah
right and they take something else like
just being really committed to that
um and that will play out for you yeah
um we spoke a lot didn't we about uh
funny obviously send like six years ago
we spoke a lot about when preparing for
this about your journey with you know
being Megan at work
why don't you talk to us a bit about
that because I think like I feel like
that's also then gonna you know be hand
in hand with you you know being a good
manager and a good leader if you truly
feel like you know you can be authentic
and be yourself
um how would you and I'm I'll wear like
this word authentic like normal almost
be overused and I feel like
but like looking back what if you were
to say yeah I wasn't that authentic like
what is it what does that actually look
like like
I think just like
I I went for a period of time where
before
before you'd walk in the office I almost
had to like take a deep breath and
almost like put on a different version
of me to adapt to that company and like
and that that's really tiring like
that's really tiring like not not being
yourself in the day and then finishing
working me like right now now I can
breathe do for you like what would you
would you sound indifferent did you have
different opinions like what you know
when you put that mask on what does that
then mean are you
you know I think it just was like again
this is like early stages I think it was
just just doing doing what I was told
almost so it's right to an extent like
feeling like I'm not I'm not quite like
there yet to be
given advice on how I think that things
should be run and things like that so
almost like biting my tongue and just
being like subservient to the business
into the role and like
um yeah and also like I used to recruit
for like hedge funds and Banks and I
used to have to dress corporate and that
is just absolutely not a bit of me
um so that that tied into it as well you
know like I didn't you know I didn't I
didn't feel like I was being who I
wanted to be
um and also naturally like right like
I've been in recruitment all my 20s
everyone in their 20s finds out like
grows in themselves and like who you
actually are from from when you're like
a teenager so I think that was like an
evolvement of that as well and then
yeah one once like I did switch
companies it was like oh I can actually
be myself like be myself like not like
it took me a little while to realize
that actually I can just walk into the
office and just be my normal self and
not have to like be super like corporate
and not who I am not who I am really
um then how did that help you
just made just made life a lot easier
like less strain on just like your your
day today and it and it just helped it
just so much easier in life if you can
just like be
be yourself like the whole time and not
have to just like constantly be fake I
just I just think it's draining was you
concerned about other people's opinions
yeah for sure was that a big part of it
that's that's always been
a big struggle for me
um I think yeah there's always like that
voice in the backy head that's like
you're not good enough and things like
that
um I you know an element of that is like
self-pressure like and I've learned to
deal with the self-talk stems back to
having that positive attitude where
you're like talking positively to to
yourself
um
but yeah I think it's all like I have
had to shrug off in recent years like
like caring what people what people
think about me it's it's hard though
right like obviously it's really hard
but
um
yes that that powerful uh the quote of
like no one is you and that is your
power like I've really tried like Mantra
myself on that
um and just think like
someone didn't like me that that's not
that's none of my business really as
long as I you know don't go home and
think oh actually you know I did
something bad but um but yeah you just
gotta think like you can't you can't
please everyone everyone's gonna unlike
you all like appreciate your opinions
like so
yeah that that's what that's like always
been a bit of a struggle to be fair over
the years have you have you got better
at quieting than the self-talk
like what what does that actually look
like how do you you know if you know
you're having a week where you've had a
lot of rejection or things haven't gone
your way you know that voice is starting
to go Megan you're not that good mate
you've got to hear through luck yeah
hard work you don't deserve to be here
you you know you've locked your
promotion not sure you should be in this
room right now
I think um
there's no like easy answer to it I
think I think it made it easier when I
became a manager because it was almost
like like so when I was principal it's
like I could have those conversations
with myself all day and come in and like
be struggling in my mind but I think
having a team it's like I had to take
that massive step up and it's like I
have to I have to be the best version of
myself every day because they rely on me
too like they might be having a bad day
I need to be the one that like gives out
my energy to them to make them to make
them feel better so I think it's
definitely changed over the past couple
years because I've got it's like I have
more responsibility and I care about
them as well
um I think like we all have like a
lockdown story right uh I think like
during those times
um got definitely got into more like
just
mental health like I feel like I never
really like did the self-reflection
thought about like how I'm feeling and
like
um I read a lot of books you know like a
Vex King Jay Shetty like all around that
sort of like just
like The Wider aspects of like how your
mind works and and everything like that
so I think yeah that that definitely
helped as well
um yeah just just doing things to help
better help better yourself
um it's on like you're gonna have good
days and bad days oh yeah because that's
yeah that's what I whenever I struggle
mentally it's the self-doubt yeah 100
it's just like yeah you're like that I
just instantly think like I'm gonna fail
yeah
I think um
I've realized my triggers as well
like if I've had a super busy week where
I've been like burning the cans at both
ends as they say like doing flat out
days at work and then I'm doing like
social things in the evening get not
getting enough sleep not having much
like just me time
um that snowballs by a Friday like
because I'm tired because I'm run down
then I'm I'm not actually like some
Friday or sometimes my worst day because
I'm just like out of energy
um so I think it's like yeah like
preserve your energy as well like I know
that's a trigger for me if something
goes wrong on a Friday and I'm in that
mood I'm gonna take it way worse I'm
gonna speak to myself way worse than
than I normally would if I'm yeah if I'm
feeling fresh and healthy
and then as as we come to the the end
here then
look I never like to uh assume
um people have experienced or
felt certain things but I I shared a
view you know and preparing for this
like
um my experience of reaching out to to
women and recruitment about coming on
the podcast and yeah you know 50 of uh
women I found that I reach out to
um sort of their instant responses not
sure I'm good enough or why would people
want to listen to my story
um but 100 of the time you know
um when I reach out to guys it's yeah it
would definitely be up for that
like correct if I'm wrong but you you're
the uh only female manager
in your business yeah so like what's
been your experience like I'm I'm I
don't think it's right for me to assume
you're a woman which means you've
experienced these things yeah right so
like you tell me because I did a post
about it and a lot of people you know
shared some really interesting things
and there's
um a number of books that I definitely
want to check out and read that a lot of
people recommended like there's so many
things to it but what what's been your
journey in building out you know this
career and being in rooms where you
might be uh you know the only woman or
yeah you're surrounded by men it is hard
as hard as it is you have to almost like
shrug that like
I'm a woman so I'm Different like I know
I know it's like it is really really
hard I've gone through massive massive
struggles on it like previously but you
just have to think like you're you're
there for a reason like for an absolute
reason like just because you're like
gender that does not matter again comes
back to like
you're you're you like no one else you
you've got here no we're not like you're
in the like sometimes it can be hard
um but yeah let's face it like
recruitment is male male dominated like
have all my teamers guys
um that I managed so it's yeah it's hard
but I think you just have to like
keep um
just keep like being really driven and
keep wanting to progress yourself and
like you're there because you're good at
you're good at what you do like you have
to keep telling yourself that I know
it's it can be a difficult thing but um
you just gotta like almost
yeah just like Empower yourself
um and realize like you might be a role
model for other people as well I think
that's really important
yeah that's what I always say to people
like the fact that you feel like that is
exactly why we should do this or yeah
because there'll be other people that
feel like that that you could Inspire or
be a role model for or because
like that that must be uh tough right
um you know if you're managing a team of
guys I'm assuming then that means like
it might it must be tough like and I'm
assuming here but I can imagine
something must be tough where like you
look ahead of you in terms of like right
I want to be a sales director or
director and like there's no you know
female person in that role or has gone
on that Journey that can sometimes be
hard to connect with or like maybe that
just you know goes into your mind of
life is it possible yeah do you know
what I mean yeah maybe
um you just you just got to tell
yourself it's possible yeah
um one of my first managers taught me a
quote of like if if not you then who if
if not now then when and that's like
stuck with me like you just got I think
like
just just do it for yourself like do it
you couldn't like Inspire other people
um and yeah like be the first like why
not like go go for it so what are you
what are you doubling down on for the
rest of this year like you know what are
you really being mindful of to really
try and turn this year around or like
really make sure that you end the year
on a positive like what are you and the
team are really remaining focused on
doubling down on and making sure your
world class up
um
like I said definitely that Network
relation piece like putting time into
your into your week where you're just
catching up with people that like that's
going to be really important
um have multiple different Business
Development strategies like don't just
focus on one thing like sometimes I've
got like 20 ideas and I'm like this is
ridiculous I can't do all the these in
one week or one month but just I break
it down like try new things be creative
like if if you've been doing the same
thing and it's not working like try
something else like
um
speak yeah like speak to the people in
your business
um to get get different ideas like yeah
I think it all comes down to just like
doing multiple things but doing them
well and where possible just trying to
be like different like other value ads
as well no it's not just about have you
got jobs what else can you like help
them with
um
so yeah just doubling down on on that
piece
um we do want to do more events more
meetups
um like our product team did one
recently
um like women in product and that was
just like amazing like I went to it and
it just it just gives you like such a
buzz and and they've been winning like
three four clients off the back of that
which which is great so I think just
like yeah that Community piece Network
relationships that's what it's all gonna
like come down to
um yeah just love that mindset of light
you know you've been doing this for a
while but you still you're still very
much open minded to try different things
be open different things it's so
important to maintain that yeah for sure
I've done some wacky things to get
clients like I've I I've gone to an
office where they've never even replied
to me or picked up my calls like
delivering a gift like I Photoshop my
face onto like the craziest of things
like
um so yeah just just try try something
different like you don't know what you
don't know if um like what could happen
um put yourself out there
again it's been a pleasure thank you
thank you